hello everyone welcome back to the
channel for another cobra kai interview
because you guys know i cannot get
enough i am so thrilled to welcome back
the executive producers of cobra kai
john hurwitz hayden schlossberg and josh
heald hello yet again congratulations
and thank you
thank you great to see you i
am so sorry for what i'm about to put
you guys through but i have a lot of
very specific questions but first i
wanted to ask one non-spoiler question
because i catch myself thinking about
this all the time and i think it might
apply to film series more than a
continuing tv series but i was wondering
how much do you consider growing your
audience every single season because you
know i know you want people to start
with season one and see the story
through but when you're crafting a new
season do you ever consider how someone
who has not seen the previous seasons
might respond so that you can gain a new
fan that way
um hayden you look like you were nodding
so i'll let you uh go yeah i mean i i
there's so many movies that i remember
watching as a kid that were the sequel
you know uh whether that's like the
rocky movies i i didn't see the first
rocky i was
you know i wasn't born yet but rocky iii
happened to be on tv when i saw it for
that first time and that got me into uh
that world and so we know when a new
season comes out there are people
there's so many options today that it's
easy to miss a great show so we know
that you know it's
there's some newbie out there that's uh
just you know flipping through whatever
the options are and
you know when they watch it we want them
to get into it so we always are writing
for
an audience that's you know
new to the the show you know we try
obviously you know if you if it's you're
in season four and so we're picking up
things from the past but we try to even
summarize a little bit at the in the
first episodes just in case like you
know people don't have uh the best
memory of all time and so we try to make
it as accessible as possible to new fans
for sure i bring that up specifically
because i think you guys do it quite
well
all right let us full-blown spoilers
right now uh all right first question i
have is specifically about kenny and
anthony because the the main ensemble is
growing here and i thought that you
could very easily have just followed the
original group of characters from grade
to grade as they get older but now
you're also going back to middle school
with these two characters kenny being
new and anthony's role being beefed up
pretty significantly so why was now the
right time to add the younger
perspective to the situation
you know uh after a few seasons you know
most of our original cast they know
karate already uh so there's something
that's uh you know really
special about you know the original
karate kid and that you know that
kid who's been bullied that kid who
could use martial arts in their life and
learning this new this new thing that
can either help them in life and you
know on our show sometimes it helps them
sometimes it hurts them uh you get a
little mixed bag there but you know we
wanted to have a new generation of
characters uh experiencing
the uh
this karate world and this karate drama
for the very first time
uh you know anthony's a character that
has sort of been hiding in plain sight
this whole time we've always loved him
for his his punch lines but now that
he's gotten older we felt like it was
time to bring him into the karate kid uh
into the kobrikai story in a bigger way
but in a more surprising way what if
daniel russo the ultimate underdog
realizes that he's been raising a kid
who's been bullying somebody else uh and
kenny uh this was a new character that
we absolutely love um you know he has
because we are talking spoilers he does
have a tie to uh characters from the
past sean and juvie who uh knows robbie
very well uh but you know to bring these
characters in and new characters like
devin uh it's been exciting to kind of
expand uh on our karate kids you do it
too well i know we spoke about it in our
non-spoiler uh conversation but like
very very very impressed by how many
different story lines you're juggling
this season and
how they actually all weave together and
serve one another it's very very
challenging thing to pull off from my
limited perspective at least
let's talk terry silver
because it's very easy for me to imagine
terry silver being in you know a very
similar place at the start of the season
where he was at in karateka three you
know rich ruthless and eager to help
crease so what inspired the idea to have
him at a completely different starting
point at the beginning of season four
it's probably you know the same way we
looked at johnny and daniel at the top
of uh the series you know what are the
colors we can show that call back to our
memories and our feelings about these
characters but what are the colors we
can also show
that you know demonstrate a real
grounded passage of time and you know
for some characters
that led to more resentment for some
characters that meant more you know more
enlightenment uh you know terry silver
has always been coming he's always been
looming just over the horizon for us so
we've been thinking about it for quite
some time and you have to jump right
back in and he's it's hard to imagine an
even more megalomaniacal version of
terry silver than that that already
existed um in karate kid 3. so
we went the other way we went you know
towards somebody who acknowledges you
know the the ills of their past and
acknowledges their problems and has been
through
something of a healing uh and something
of you know confronting um their their
cells but
we all knew that there would still be
something
living underneath this character there
would still be these deep-seated
feelings that didn't go away that
weren't dealt with this you know this
mixture of ptsd and you know survivor's
guilt and all of the the allegiance that
he has you know to crease at the cobra
kai
really was under that kind of volcanic
rock that had you know just covered the
terry silver we once knew and it was uh
that that was the satisfying story to
tell was kind of beginning to to see
how do we jackhammer away at that uh at
that crust
with all that in mind in episode five
when terry apologizes to daniel was it
truly earnest and if daniel had had a
different response to the apology would
things have panned out better
i i think that
we like to think that that is the case
uh you know people can interpret it any
different way you know terry is a
complicated character even for us but i
think
we like to think that he was actually
trying to go about this a little bit
more level-headedly
and that daniel larusso because of his
ptsd and also if you see credit kit 3
how can you blame daniel for for
trusting this guy i mean all he does is
show up at mr miyagi's house with crazy
lies so
um you know it makes so much sense for
you know terry to be
bullshitting you know
uh
a change of heart and
you know so it it was the perfect kind
of recipe for daniel of miscommunication
and misinterpretation for daniel to tell
him to just go get get the hell out of
here and be rude to him so much so that
it kind of like
pisses terry off a little bit and and
and starts to fan that flame of uh a bad
guy in him um so yeah who you know had
had daniel just left well enough alone
and
not been such a hot head you know maybe
uh maybe it wouldn't have the season
wouldn't have ended the way it did i
feel like i watched it the first time
with that lens and and very much
understood why daniel reacted the way he
did and when i saw the whole thing
through and got to watch it again and
look for those nuances i'm like huh
you know his intentions weren't all bad
all the time and i think that speaks to
thomas ian griffith's work who is just
like walks right back into that role
does so much more with it but also feels
like he never took a break from the role
at all it's incredible
yeah yeah i would say you know first of
all working with thomas was a total
dream um you know we we've all been fans
for a long time and been waiting for
this day where he would return to the
show um but we've also gotten to know
robert mark heyman pretty well who
created the karate kid films and every
time we had spoken with him about thomas
he would rave about him not only as a
performer as a martial artist as a
person
all these things and it's been proven on
set and you know he came in this is this
was a guy who had been working as a
writer primarily for the last many many
years and had sort of left acting behind
him for a bit and he stepped back on set
like
like somebody who's been acting every
single day for their entire adult life
uh a true pro in every way and the
layers that uh he brings to his
performance are phenomenal
all right let's talk a little bit about
crease now this might be something
you're exploring in the future but i
still have to ask
why does chris think he needs terry so
so badly is it strictly because of you
know the fighting and how he thinks
terry can help train the students or or
is there something deeper to that
i think kris is uh you know he's always
been a war general he's always looking
at the battlefield he's always looking
how does he
outflank the enemy you know how can he
be thinking one step ahead you know up
until the point that silver comes into
this story and turns the tables
crease is playing more three-dimensional
chess than johnny or daniel and johnny
or daniel reacting to some of the moves
that kris is making you know once johnny
and daniel you know pretty much
annihilate crease at the end of season
three and you know he has just a breath
where he can still stand up and kind of
spit in their face you know it's it's he
still has to admit to himself that he he
wants someone to lean on he needs a
lieutenant you know he needs you know at
least just another body there if they're
teaming up i'm teaming up like he's not
gonna leave himself at a disadvantage uh
you know he's not prideful in the way
where he's you know going to go out and
give it his all and whether we win or
lose doesn't matter this is a guy who's
only about winning and you know if
they're going to throw every tool they
have at him he's going to throw every
tool he has at them
uh another crease moment that i
absolutely loved was the conversation he
had with amanda in the supermarket did
did crease genuinely have good
intentions there it's every time he says
something especially with the two of
them it comes across as menacing but
that that felt like
one of the most purest i just want to
help this girl kind of conversations he
could have had in that moment
yeah i think uh you know we think of
crease and the back story that we kind
of you know created for him uh in season
three where you you get the sense you
know he had uh
uh
sort of
you know sick mother maybe mentally ill
mother and
that he is kind of protective not not
just of women but of anybody who has
that kind of a situation and i think he
recognizes that
in tory
and i think he in that scene also
respects amanda and how she's acting
uh
about sam he says you know you know
that
um he has some line i forget what it was
about like a mother should you know
be looking after their daughter the way
she uh she was so
you know i think
he he values motherhood a lot um based
on his backstory and so there's a little
bit of respect i also think the fact
that she went in and slapped him last
year there's a little bit of uh
you know respect there
and but i think he did really go there
to kind of you know
uh
just kind of you know back her have her
back down a little bit because
he knows that you know the russos if
they wanted to could put her in jail
the
the tory amanda situation was was one of
the most uh
satisfying surprises of me for the
season so
how did you come to the conclusion that
that amanda was the right character to
help facilitate i guess a more
redemptive arc in tory because i mean if
you had asked me last year or even
before i i never thought that amanda
would have been the one to put tori on a
better path of all of the people in play
here
i think that's exactly why we we went
with her um you know it's it's
surprising she's the character who
you know is most anti-tory she's a mama
bear who protects her
her daughter
um and you know this girl kind of led a
charge into her home so this is somebody
who thinks that tory's a psychopath um
but amanda has
consistently been a uh
level-headed and empathetic empathetic
character she's she's somebody who is
caring and if she's going to learn a
little bit more information as she does
in this season about the realities of
tory's life
uh you know she's able to
uh
[Applause]
see things in a in a more well-rounded
way than maybe some of the other
characters on our show do beyond that we
just love courtney hankler she's one of
our favorite performers on the show
she's hilarious um she's always games
she's such a wonderful
actress and we wanted her to be able to
to stretch her legs a little bit more
and do something uh a little bit
different uh
in her arc this season and the scenes
whenever we were filming the scenes with
those two women it was it's a phenomenal
day on set do you have a favorite
courtney line of the season
cool
i'm i'm blanking right now because we're
we're in the middle of filming season
five
so like i'm
so it's it's so far removed at this
moment i can't even think of a specific
line but the whole interaction uh with
the soup was just
something about the way that that built
and then the the laughs that you
included in it were just like pitch
perfect
it's that's drawn out of that every now
and then a little bit of curvier
enthusiasm enters the show and there's
nothing that bothers us more than seeing
our hot food just
sitting waiting while the you know
server is not doing anything so we
injected that in there i definitely have
a little of that in me it it hit me
pretty hard all right very random little
thing here but did you ever consider
leaving uh robbie with a scar on his
forehead because i think of star wars a
lot when i watch your show and it would
have felt very star wars-y to me
yeah i don't know if it reads at all but
definitely in that first episode we did
put a little something on his head uh
like a bruise that we wanted to like
kind of slowly fade away uh we did we
always think of scars on this show we've
we've certainly given them to characters
uh before um a couple you know evident
in this season um but i think right in
the dead center of the head is uh is a
big big decision and
uh we didn't really have anywhere to go
with that in terms of what we were going
to be digging into storywise with him so
it felt like you know on the
in the makeup trailer when you already
got you know jacob with the you know the
mohawk and the lip scar and the back
tattoo and mary with the scar and you
know and then it was just the tonnage of
scars uh we didn't want to leave um just
a valley full of scarred children at the
end of the day so his bruise uh did heal
very understandable speaking of hawk i i
guess was the only way forward for hawk
to lose the hawk or did you ever explore
any alternatives
no that that was the original story and
we had been thinking about that in while
we were making season three you know
that uh
as soon as you know he leaves that dojo
uh that's the ultimate payback and that
it would be that um
that kind of classic samson
ask story of like you lose your hair you
lose the power um but then at the end
you know can he find that power within
was was it the was it the hair or was it
the mojo
and uh you know we love
incorporating hair into storylines and
character arcs and there's probably
never been anything as you know
uh
you know that uses hair as much as we do
when it comes to a character's journey
as with when it comes to hawks so
uh and you'll see it it continues as the
story unfolds there's
there's more uh
there's more hawks story and and hair
story uh yet to come i like hearing that
but i do wonder are there any nerves
when you do something like that that
you know you'll disappoint fans as as
far as a surface level thing goes
because you you kind of set it to an
extent but it's almost like like you're
you're teaching eli the same lesson that
you have to teach the audience that this
character isn't defined by this really
cool thing that we've all become
obsessed with
you know i think
part of part of making the show part of
the storytelling is knowing that there
are moments that you're creating on the
show that are going to upset the fan
base um and at times disturb the fan
base
and uh you know i'll be honest there are
times where we'll watch you know we see
the reaction videos that people do
online occasionally in the compilations
and we you know we enjoy watching the
appropriate reaction to things like if
even like miguel falling off the balcony
that's a tragic horrible moment but for
us when you see a reaction video and
people are
truly upset and devastated it means we
did our job correctly so you know and
again and beyond that just when you have
something so upsetting happen to a
character and you know it's when we're
talking about the hair with hawks
something that's so defining and such a
big part of his character
you know you
you need to reset things you need to to
tell the story and with with low points
come high points at a later time you
know or perhaps more low points so these
are the this is the roller coaster of of
telling the story and uh it's all part
of it
with that in mind is there any
particular scene in season four that
when you guys watch these reaction
videos you're gonna scrub directly to
that scene and you're really curious to
see how people respond
oh man i mean season four like you said
at the top is
huge i mean it's our biggest season yet
it has more story lines and more
characters and
more just worlds to explore within you
know the valley than we've ever done
before um i really just want people to
go all in on the all valley i mean when
we
when we made those episodes uh we knew
we were you know we were swinging for
the fences and you know we decided
pretty early on
let's do two episodes let's construct
kind of a movie unto itself within this
season and there's so many twists and
turns and reveals and moments um that
happen in there i mean i want people to
be
you know jumping out of their seats
surprised when you know carrie underwood
walks on the screen i want people to be
feeling the adrenaline of the skills
tournament i want you know people to
be you know just totally like you know
on the edge of their seat for you know
the boys and girls finals there's so
many moments that are so built toward
you know goosebumps and
and fist pumping and excitement and but
really i want to see you know the the
last moment of the entire series i want
to see that reaction because when that
camera wraps around ralph and you
realize he wasn't just talking you know
to mr miyagi's headstone but here comes
chosen you know and and hell is coming
with him i want to see i want to see
people you know react to that because i
know how i feel about that and you know
i still feel that way and we shot that a
long time ago
i just want to add a couple things real
quick uh terry silver's turn on crease
the the like we love nothing more than
when he's sort of like almost dancing to
his own score at the very end of that
scene and then everything stingray i
want to see what people's reaction when
stingray shows up on screen and the fun
of that but then what happens to
stingray at the end of the episode with
terry silver that's one of those things
that's just a gut punch um so you know
you want to see those kinds of big
reactions
and i also i just adding to that i think
like in season in episode five you know
and we're trying not to show it too much
in marketing i hope you know people
aren't figuring out but like johnny and
daniel just fighting each other like the
sensei's going at it and
you know you might think that that would
be something that we build to in the
last episode of the last season or
something like that we love the idea of
just like
you know well it would come to this
point and treat that as a really like
big mid-season uh moment so i as soon as
like the fans
watched that episode and realized wait
that's happening now and this whole
episode's about it um
looking forward to seeing that reaction
for sure oh my god i have so many
follow-ups also your stunts team i know
they've gotten a whole lot of love but
there there are some sequences in this
season in particular where that love
better continue
the tournament
did you ever uh play around with who
would make it to the finals or in your
mind was it always those four
individuals
um it was always those four individuals
there there were discussions there are
different ways that it it could have
gone
um with those four individuals because i
think
it started the first decision was
miguel's not going to be in the finals
and the reasoning for that
for us was
you know
in terms of his character growth he's
already won at the all valley and in
some ways him deciding not to fight and
caring about something else and
realizing that wait he may be fighting
for the wrong reasons as he's you know
listening to johnny talk in the last
episode
you know that was more kind of a
character growth moment for him than
actually like going in and winning and
say you know saving the day and so as
soon as we made that decision you start
to think okay well who's going to end up
in the finals
and you know who's those for and i think
we just you know wanted a situation
where going into the end it was
you know the quote-unquote good guys
miyagi and nyagido and eagle fang that
are behind and need uh you know
need to win both matches in order to end
up uh you know winning the tournament so
they're in that underdog position going
into the finals
and so and then it laid out where
you know i think we felt that tory's
story
you know there was the most uh character
depth and growth for her to win but then
at the end realize that this trophy that
earlier in the season you hear her
talking about how it pretty much may be
the highlight of her life given what she
thinks her future is going to be
um you know to to see that trophy and
realize it's it's illegitimate you know
it was like for us a great ending point
um so and so we and and as you said with
hawke you know he loses that mohawk in
the middle of the season that's like the
lowest point for the characters we
wanted him to have an awesome high point
and so those are it's all about like
where we want to see the characters
where we see them going later in the
series
and what their journey has been for that
particular season
this is a very little detail and it
might be my ears failing me but i've
also re-watched the scene quite a few
times and there is no subtitle for it
after tori wins she goes up to sam and
asks she asks if she's all right and
then sam says something back to her what
what does she say back to tori in that
moment
sam says uh what i think she's very
surprised um that tori is actually like
saying something nice to her and it's
such a
moment where all you know all the
adrenaline from the fight is draining
out of her head and she's a little bit
discombobulated and she almost is
checking her own ears you know she's
saying what
so that it had the same effect on me i
could read that on her face but i'm like
am i missing something and then i'm
doubting myself the entire time
um
i i think i know the answer to this but
i'm curious from your perspectives why
call episode nine the fall and episode
10 the rise
uh you know it was
the uh
the it's really the endings uh play uh a
role in that you know for it's you know
the fall of miguel again you know with
that kind of uh you know bringing that
back and then the rise of uh you know
terry silver it's the rise of cobra kai
and and terry silver sort of emerging on
top were sort of uh
the the the big you know focal points to
me are there any additional uh things
that i'm forgetting well i'll say also
our fandom is very um creative about you
know figuring out our titles ahead of
time i think they have to be registered
with the wga website at some point and
there's a lot of interpretations that go
into them so we're always looking at it
with that angle at this point in the
series of how can we
thematically talk about the episode in
the title that feels
meaningful to you know the other titles
that we have but also how can we um
obfuscate a little bit in terms of what
what that might mean um it's you know so
it's staying honest but also subverting
it's frustrating because sometimes we
have some really good titles that we end
up just not using because
they're too they'll give away too much
like i remember for season three i liked
the idea of season finale with an i
um
and
it would have been great but our fans
would figure that out so you know
it's you know we have to find that way
to be vague and also apropos
all right i'm gonna have to let you guys
go soon you have work to do but i wanted
to ask just like one overall serious
question i'm not sure how many seasons
you originally
envisioned the show being when you first
got started but how has your plan for
the full series storyline changed over
the years based on new things you
discovered while making season season
season season
i'll say like we
there are characters and story lines
that we've considered that you know from
the beginning we would have said okay
that's a season
and that storyline ended up being
you know an episode or two and then
there's the opposite of that where you
say okay this is a season and no we're
going to extend that into multiple
seasons um so you know we've we've
always looked back at our original plan
with open eyes because with so many new
branches and so many new characters and
interactions and what you're seeing
during production when oh wow these two
people together there's something you
know interesting about that duo you want
to lean more into it and when you do
lean more into it it naturally you know
pushes other things along and further
out um
so
you know it's it's changed at times but
it but it also hasn't we still have an
endgame plan uh we're still writing
beyond season five um and uh but but
it's but it's been fun to kind of bring
in those new characters and story lines
and let them lead the way sometimes
yeah we've never said we've never said
from the beginning how many seasons
there would be i think we always viewed
it as at least six was sort of in our
heads um but you know we're we're still
figuring out exactly what that landing
that the the uh the length for that
landing is at for all the reasons that
josh mentioned
more seasons and spin-offs please very
demanding do our best
i'm going to end with a very selfish
question because i just want to make
this official so
johnny's drink of choice is coors
banquet or i should say beer of choice
because i know daniel has has other
feelings spanish drinks but daniel's
beer of choice is blue moon now right
yes
that officially makes me miyagido i
think
you know we drink it all we're not uh
we're not snobs we'll have the martini
and the banquet and the blue moon and
you know amanda's wine and you know
whatever they're drinking you know we're
happy to partake it's literally all i
drink i go into a craft beer place and
i'm like what's the closest thing you
have to blue moon
and then they want to kick it out i have
to let you go again
congratulations season four is excellent
i've got all the faith in the world in
season five and beyond cannot wait to
see more
thanks perry thanks great talking